Nan is a politician who for decades has
based his public Appeal on security on
the idea that I am the most responsible
Steward of Israeli security and he's now
presided over the biggest security
failure in Israel in half a century so
it is hard to imagine this uh is
anything other than the end of his
political career he's going to try and
avoid that one thing he's going to do is
try to shift the blame onto the heads of
the military and the security services
there's a reason if you go through a
list of former Israeli Army Chiefs or
Assad directors who served under
Netanyahu the vast majority of them when
they leave office end up being very very
sharp critics of the Prime Minister
because when things go well he takes
credit and things go badly someone else
is always to blame so he's going to try
and shift the blame but I I don't see
that working when the inevitable early
elections are called when the dust
settles it's it's really hard to imagine
this is not the end of his career as
prime minister